JONATHAN: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to this week's Google+
platform office hours.
I'm joined by Richard Dunn,
who is the tech lead for
Google+ Hangouts, as well as
Jason Salas, and the one only
Allen Firstenberg.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
Hey, everybody.
JONATHAN: Oh, and Jenny Murphy
is coming on stage right now.
There she is.
So first and foremost, I want
to thank Richard for joining
us this week.
It's an honor to have one of
the members of the Hangouts
API team join this
office hours.
He's busy, as we're trying
to get more releases out
as often as we can.
We have a few questions for
him to answer later in the
show, as well as questions from
the folks who joined us.
I think for this Office Hours,
we'll be a little bit more
free form, and as questions
come in we'll
start to address those.
Not as a particular topic
to start with.
So how about I just start with
Richard, saying, what's going
on with Hangouts API?
What's the current
scene of things?
And what would you like to
tell the audience first?
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah.
So hi, guys.
I'm Richard, tech lead
for Hangouts API.
I assume that most people are
aware that we launched
publicly just about
a month ago.
So we're really excited to have
stuff out there and see
people building apps,
releasing apps.
We're interested to see
what can happen.
We spent a lot of time of
getting that public release
going, so we're now being able
to have some time to go back
and beef up the API some more.
So we're also interested in
hearing from people, you know,
what do you need for us
to build for you?
Trying to make it easier
to write apps,
that kind of thing.
So easier to write apps, easier
to distribute apps,
easier to find and use
apps in the Hangout.
All that kind of stuff is things
we're thinking about
and working on.
JASON SALAS: Very cool.
JONATHAN: So for Jason, I
think-- is this your first
time in Office Hours?
JASON SALAS: Yeah.
I actually-- normally, because
of the time difference between
you fine folks and me, I usually
catch it on demand.
But I was really interested in
participating today just
because the focus was going
to be specifically on the
Hangouts API, which, like Allen,
I have taken a great
interest in and done a fair
amount of tinkering in.
And I actually, I'm trying
to get several Hangouts
API-centric projects
off the ground, and
everything like that.
So I'm really excited to be
speaking with you and Jenny
and Richard.
All of you have been extremely
gracious and really, really
quick to respond in the
past and everything.
Every time we have questions and
everything, so it's a real
treat to be interacting with
you guys live this time.
And it's 4:30 in the
morning on Thursday
where I am right now.
Even though for you
guys it's like 11.
JONATHAN: You're not in the
States-- you're not stateside.
Where are you again?
JASON SALAS: I'm in Guam.
So I am about 3 and 1/2 hours
south of Japan and 8 and 1/2
hours north of Hawaii.
That's 15 hours ahead
of you guys.
So you're literally talking to
somebody from the future.
JONATHAN: Oh, how is
it in the future?
Is [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON SALAS: It's hot.
It's hot here.
It's very, very hot.
It's 4:30 in the morning and
it's about 89 degrees already.
RICHARD DUNN: So can you talk a
little bit about some of the
projects you're thinking
about doing?
I feel like I've seen you around
on Twitter, but it'd be
great to hear about them.
JASON SALAS: Oh, yeah.
Twitter, it's lots of sports
one-liners and everything, but
hopefully something
with a little bit
more substance here.
So basically, I kind of had--
and this obviously is not a
completely new idea, but I was
talking with some friends in a
Hangout, you know, on my stream,
and I just kind of
thought, I was like, why isn't
there a Hangout app right now
that lets paid Netflix
subscribers be able to
actually basically host
movie parties?
And I kind of came up with the
notion that movie watching and
the act of enjoying movies
can be a social
experience if you so desire.
For some people, they're very
private relaxation activities,
and for other people they're
more of a party atmosphere.
And so I started thinking about
it, and I was like, you
know, if you're a paid Netflix
subscriber, you should be able
to share those kind of
experiences with other Netflix
subscribers.
And I know obviously there's a
whole bunch of intellectual
property concerns.
And there's huge issues about,
is that going to be piracy?
And can you lock it down so that
movies don't get stolen
and everything like that?
But I actually started thinking,
and I started look
at other platforms. And of
course, on the Xbox 360 they
had previously had a party
mode where if you were a
legitimate Netflix subscriber,
you and other members could
sign in and then you
could basically
watch a movie together.
And up until the December,
2011 firmware update, I
believe, that existed.
But it's since been taken out.
So I was thinking, can this
kind of thing actually be
built legally and safely
and securely with
the Hangouts platform?
And I would think that
it could be.
So I guess long story short, now
that I've rambled on, as a
developer, what kind of control
do I have to say, if I
build an app and everything,
to ensure that it will not
work in a Hangout
On Air scenario.
Regardless of this
implementation or in something
else, if I write something, is
there a guarantee, or do I
have programmatic control to
say this will not run in a
Hangout On Air in a
live broadcast?
RICHARD DUNN: We don't
have that right now.
And I think as part of preparing
for a broader
release of the On Air stuff,
there's actually a bunch of
things we need to do
to just make sure
everything works great.
And I guess one of the obvious
things will be, should this
app be able to run
in an On Air?
I don't think that's something
we thought about.
We thought about more--
As an example, I have the
volume control app up.
And there's six participants,
not five, because there's the
magic On Air participant.
So we should probably
be fixing that.
Yeah, I mean, that's
a good point.
I don't know if you'd want
to do it like, don't
ever let this run.
So don't even show this
in a Hangout On Air.
Or whether you'd just want to
let the application know, hey,
this is an On Air Hangout, and
then the application can
decide to show something where
it's like, this is not
available in an On Air.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I think there
are also some things--
JASON SALAS: Because right now
I know, and Alan and I are
contributors to Google
Plus week.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Allen.
I was going to say because you
and I are both contributors to
Google+ Week, and Dan McDermott,
the show host on
That Show has at times said,
if I bring up a Google doc,
because I wanted to interact
with a guest, that's not going
to show up I guess
just by default.
Because it won't come out
on the recording.
Like you were saying, Richard,
hopefully in the future,
either by design of the actual
core program, or maybe from a
developer's standpoint, this
will just be something that we
can maybe just easily apply,
just turn on or off.
And just say, exclude this
from a live broadcast
scenario, either because it's
just going to be goofy, or
just because there are privacy
concerns or whatever.
RICHARD DUNN: And again, it's
not as big of a problem now
just because the apps aren't
available, they're not going
to show up on the recording.
But I think that's obviously a
place that we want to get to.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I think one
of the things that we need to
start evolving towards when
we're talking about the
integration of apps and On Air
is a way for some of the apps
to be able to control, for the
person who owns the On Air
account to be able to control
the recording in User.
RICHARD DUNN: Right.
So-- go ahead.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: So for now
for example, I know that if
that person clicks on one of the
thumbnails on the bottom,
that will be the primary stream
that's recorded, that's
send out On Air.
That kind of control in an
API fashion would also be
beneficial.
And I'm sure there are others.
It's that sort of thing.
RICHARD DUNN: Right.
So as I said, we definitely have
sort of an open project
to do the On Air stuff.
And there is definitely a plan
to expose the sort of
privileges that the
broadcaster has--
like I think [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and that kind of thing--
as an API so that people
can write--
I mean, ideally, we will want
people to be able to write an
extension or whatever that's
a better version of the
broadcast controls.
And that extension would be
aware that, hey, this person
is the broadcaster and I
can actually do this.
And if they're not the
broadcaster and they try to do
is, it'll just fail on them.
But we definitely want to expose
that, and we would just
expose that in the way of,
there'll obviously be a call
that's like, is this person
the broadcaster?
And if they are, you have
all these other calls
available to you.
JONATHAN: And I would say that
as you guys are thinking about
how that would work, as
developers and designers and
that, the feedback
to us directly.
You do already.
And anybody who's watching this
live or the according,
send it our way, both to Jenny
and I and the rest of the
team, and we can double
that up and help out
with the API side.
JENNIE MURPHY: Definitely.
JASON SALAS: OK.
Well, I have another question,
if I may, for Richard.
And actually, for all of
you, including Allen.
One of my favorite examples is
the very excellent demo that
Jonathan has actually showed
many times live in his
presentations.
The one where you have the
little avatars of each
participant, and the
he goes around.
Like the initial version of
that, I think Wolff may have
written it specifically.
But takes a drink or dances
around, you know,
unwraps a candy bar.
And the most recent one was
flies and gets out of there to
actually get down to
South by Southwest.
And Jonathan, you actually
mentioned that there was,
because it's built in flash,
that there was a
communications bridge that
was very easy to do.
Again, because what I'm looking
at doing right now is
hopefully trying to integrate
Netflix, which I believe for
most people is based
on Silverlight.
So do you know?
Because I'm just ignorant
of that thing.
Do you know if there is a
Flashlight bridge that we use
to communicate with Silverlight
applications?
JONATHAN: Yeah.
So in Flash there's a series
of methods that's called
External Interface.
So it allows you to call
JavaScript externally, and
there's a way to do the reverse
from Flash to pass
that back up.
Silverlight has a similar API.
I don't know it--
I've never programmed
Silverlight.
But I know if you Google
external interface
Silverlight, you'll find
the right path.
Probably through Stack Overflow,
if I were to guess.
And I could also send you
that after the show.
JASON SALAS: All right.
Excellent.
Thank you.
JONATHAN: No problem.
JENNIE MURPHY: Cool.
So are there any more, any other
questions for people
currently present?
Otherwise, I'll start going to
the comments feeds and we'll
answer some more app questions
from the passive audience who
are watching us on YouTube
or on Google+.
JASON SALAS: Well, if I--
JONATHAN: Yeah, go ahead.
JASON SALAS: I'm sorry.
I'm just going to say, if I
could just be a motor mouth
for just 10 more seconds.
One other concern I had, and
it's kind of a minor one, was,
because I've done some HTML 5
work as far as video game
development.
And developers have in
that space is kind
of a concern for--
because now we can actually
list our applications and
extensions in the Chrome
web store.
And for those people that
actually want to maybe
commercialize this, is there a
way as developers where we
could actually maybe obfuscate
the code that we ultimately
write so that it won't be so
easy to just go in and look
through and see what
we're doing.
Or in some way actually lock
down the logic just so it's
not so easy to reverse engineer
what we're doing.
RICHARD DUNN: Right.
I mean, there's a variety of
ways to compile and in some
sense JavaScript.
Obviously, Google's Closure
stuff has ways
to compile it down.
Like if you look at the actual
Hangouts code, if you were
really into it, you could
probably figure out what it
was doing, but it
just makes it--
it increases that bar
so much further.
In general, we haven't been
facing that situation because
the apps that we've been writing
are sort of like we'd
like you to see them and
how we do things.
But there are definitely
solutions
that compile it down.
JONATHAN: I'd add to that.
Closure Compile is great.
We use it across Google.
There's a recent addition to
Chrome which makes using that
not only better for
a developer, but
also still the same.
It's called Source Maps.
And what that does is it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] your
JavaScript code--
it obfuscates it and tries to
reduce the complexity of it--
and then it also spits out this
file called Source Map.
It's sort of like your
Rosetta Stone for
your obfuscated code.
So all you have to do is plug
that into Chrome, and then
your code gets cleaned
up and legible again.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah.
Un-obfuscated.
So if you have access to the
Source Map, actually it looks
clean to you.
JONATHAN: So that's a super
powerful tool-- really want to
try to develop it.
JASON SALAS: Excellent.
And I was actually thinking more
from the standpoint of
people who might use apps that
write, not necessarily because
I want to mangle my own code
just so people won't be able
to reverse engineer it.
I'm just thinking, you know,
how easy would it be for
somebody to go in there
and actually pick
up on what I'm doing.
Because yeah, like you guys,
right now, it's a great
learning tool.
JONATHAN: So the two things
I will say about game
development, it's a little bit
tricky because if you're
building a web app that people
want to use as a utility,
they're not going
to hack around.
But in games, there's Murphy's
law that says they will hack
the game to try to get
a better score.
There's a very long and detailed
science of how to
prevent that, with Sphinx
and using servers,
and things like that.
So it's not just obfuscating
your code, but also trying to
ensure truthfulness in the state
of your applications.
So that's where using a
server-side back end to store
that and keep that truthy, as
well as obfuscated the data
over the wire and things
like that.
So just an extra tip.
JASON SALAS: Thank you.
JONATHAN: No problem.
JENNIE MURPHY: Okey doke.
I'm going to pull a question
from the common stream now.
So Tim actually asks
a few questions.
I'll read them one at
a time, we'll field
them one at a time.
So first she asks, "I have
Hangouts On Air, plus I have
streaming to YouTube capability
and I would like to
ask questions live.
Here's my question--
when will the chat stream be
incorporated into Hangout so
that it can be monitored
within the Hangout?"
I'm assuming she's asking about
the YouTube chat stream.
"Also, is there a plan to
incorporate the chat--" oh,
there it is--
"is there a plan to incorporate
the chat from
YouTube too so it can be managed
from the Hangout On
Air."
So I guess what she's asking is,
right now there's a whole
bunch of different conversation
channels
potentially for a Hangout On
Air, like the Hangout On Air
you might be watching
right now.
Are there any plans to kind
of coalesce those
communication channels?
RICHARD DUNN: So, sorry.
You were talking about
the YouTube chat?
JONATHAN: So I think her
question is, you know, I start
an On Air and there's a post
and people comment on that
post. I'd like to see those
comments inside of the chat.
Also, I have a YouTube live and
there's comments there.
People will read those folks,
It's hard [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in these multiple interface.
RICHARD DUNN: Got it, OK.
Yeah, I mean, in terms of the
post thing, putting it into
the chat in a Hangout is sort
of a delicate topic.
We have talked in the past about
doing a write interface
to the chat.
Because things like maintaining
the event history
of an app or whatever, like,
so-and-so changed the YouTube
video to something.
Getting read access to the chat
is super sensitive in
terms of privacy issues.
The other thing that people I
think are worried about this
is sort filling up that chat
with useless stuff.
But we would definitely like
to find a way to let apps
write into it.
And I think if you can let
apps write into the chat
stream, then whatever the
app can access in
terms the Google Post--
the Comment Tracker would be
an example here, right?
Where it knows the post, it can
access those comments, and
it could put them
into the chat.
And then I assume there's a
YouTube API for grabbing the
comments around a particular
video.
And then it's really just
an implementation issue.
So I think the takeaway from
that was is API-wise, we
really do need to find a way
to integrate that into the
chat stream or have a separate
stream that's like app events
and that kind of thing that
people can follow.
JONATHAN: And so for anybody
who's not familiar with
Comment Tracker, that was a
Hangout extension that was
built by Gerwin Sturm.
It allows you to grab any posts
on Google Plus, paste
the URL for that post into the
sidebar extension, and it will
actually pull in all
the comments.
So in this particular Hangout,
if you wanted to track the
post, you could follow along and
pull in those questions.
And it's one of the many Hangout
apps that we have
built by third parties.
JENNIE MURPHY: We have some
other questions that are not
directly related to
the Hangouts API.
They're more Hangouts in
general questions.
Reload.
For example, there's
one question.
"When will Hangouts On Air
come to Android?" Which I
guess is a question about
running a Hangout On Air from
a mobile device.
RICHARD DUNN: That is an
interesting question.
I don't actually know how tough
that would be to do.
JONATHAN: Yeah.
I think part of the answer is
that won't happen until
Hangouts On Air gets
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And if at that point, if
it's feasible, that's
something to look at.
But there's no plans
as far as we know.
And that's a great
idea, right?
JENNIE MURPHY: That's
a cool idea.
RICHARD DUNN: I think in general
we'd like to make the
mobile experience as
rich as possible.
And so being able to support
all that is definitely
something we'd like
to work on.
JENNIE MURPHY: Cool.
So next up--
JASON SALAS: Maybe.
JENNIE MURPHY: Sorry?
JASON SALAS: You mean
as a participant?
RICHARD DUNN: Sorry, you
broke up a little
in the middle there.
What did you say?
JASON SALAS: Oh, did I?
I'm sorry about that.
Maybe the person is asking
as a participant.
Because I'm fortunate enough
to have Hangouts On Air
access, but when my friends
invite me with other Hangouts,
other users invite me to
Hangouts, if they're going on
the air, then if I check it on
one of my mobile devices, it
says, this is not supported,
obviously, by mobile devices.
So maybe that person's even
thinking, can I at least jump
in, if not as a recorder, then
just as a contributor.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah, I mean,
that's something definitely
for me to check with
the On Air team.
It's a separate team
than I am.
But I'm actually a little
surprised that you can't joint
as just as a--
but that seems like it would
be a much easier task to
accomplish.
JENNIE MURPHY: Okey-doke.
So I have a question
from Robert Pitt.
"When will the OAuth
token be easily
accessible within the API?
Right now, users authorize the
applications but there is no
method to get the access
token within the code."
RICHARD DUNN: So Jonathan, I
thought Wolff published a
sample out that was
showing you how to
get the OAuth token.
JONATHAN: Yeah.
So with the current
implementation, they authorize
it and then you can use the
JavaScript client library to
access that token.
It is part of our Hangout
experiments, which is a
co-depository.
I don't know if we've linked
to it from the developer's
site just yet, but it's easily
available, and I think I've
even demoed that three
Office Hours ago.
If not, we can post that link
to the article on describing
how to use it.
It works well.
We have I think, for example,
Ace's Poker is
using it in their app.
And that lets you use the Google
APIs and the Google+
and every other authenticate
API under the Google stack.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah.
I mean, I think we should
definitely hook that up to the
developer's side if possible.
JONATHAN: Yeah.
And we are looking at ways to
streamline that even further
and make it a better developer
experience.
JENNIE MURPHY: But in the
meantime, we'll grab that
article from Wolff, and I will
have to the show notes near
this question.
So we have another way for
people to find it.
Great.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I've got a
follow up question on one of
the mobile questions
from earlier.
What kind of plans are in
progress for having Hangout
apps available through
the mobile clients?
RICHARD DUNN: So we've
definitely thought about it,
and it actually turns out to
be something of a hard
problem, just because there's
not a lot of support for
JavaScript in the sort of
mobile native apps.
And it's really hard to get
that communication going.
So there are some plans to look
at it from a different
way, but nothing that
I think is going to
come out anytime soon.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: That's
interesting, because there's a
lot of stuff on mobile
that's being done
with a WebKit window.
RICHARD DUNN: Right.
So from my understanding,
it's the communication.
It's the communication that
seems to be the problem.
So displaying that is fine, but
the communication across
that WebKit window to the
actual native app is--
and we have a fairly rich API
that relies on a lot of that
communication.
We might be able to do a
scaled-down version of it, but
that was my understanding
of sort of the technical
difficulty there.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: OK, thanks.
JONATHAN: And I will add that
the WebKit child iframe across
different operating systems, as
well as different versions
of operating systems,
is not consistent.
Very inconsistent.
RICHARD DUNN: As I said, as a
general rule, we're trying to
make the mobile experience as
rich as responsible, and we
certainly have that on our to-do
list. It's just given
the technical constraints and
then resource constraints,
it's probably going
to be a while.
JENNIE MURPHY: Great.
So I'm not seeing any other
Hangouts API-related
questions, but I am seeing a
couple questions about the
show and the REST API.
So I'll field these really
quickly while we wait for
those of you out there to ask
us some more questions about
the Hangouts API.
So Fabio asks, "is it possible
to search for two or more
hashtags using the
activities.search method?"
And actually, I just did some
experimentation with it, and I
got the same results you did.
Went searching for multiple
hashtags, the results just did
full text search using
the hashtags.
So right now it appears it'll
only except one hashtag as
well as any number of full
text search parameters.
I'm a little surprised by that,
so I'll be following up,
I'll be filing that as a bug.
And well, I'll follow up
with you later on that.
So I would expect
that to work.
Thanks for bringing that
to our attention.
And also, Nicolo asks, "Will we
be treated to PHP for list
activities?"
I'm assuming you're referring
to the JavaScript demo I did
last session showing you how to
use the JavaScript APIs and
the JavaScript client library
to access your activities.
Not going to be doing
that in PHP today.
We're focusing on Hangout APIs,
but in a future week
we'll be talking about that.
So thanks for your patience.
JASON SALAS: May I ask
another question?
JONATHAN: Yeah, please.
JASON SALAS: I was wondering--
and this may or may not be
anything, and I think
maybe goes more to
the Core Rest API.
And I don't believe it exists
right now, but would we be
able to actually set what level
of invitee would be able
to get either the Hangout app or
like the invite to actually
use that app.
This is a weird way
of framing it.
I guess I've got to rephrase.
Would I be able to only invite
non-public circles or
non-extended circles
to use an app?
Like, say, if you just wanted
to do it for a super private
implementation, or only invite
specific non-public circles or
individual users.
RICHARD DUNN: So I'd--
JASON SALAS: Could probably
just do it manually.
RICHARD DUNN: I guess I'm
confused as to why.
I mean, are there concerns above
and beyond creating a
Hangout with this app and
then only inviting
those select few people?
JASON SALAS: Yeah.
Because, again, going back to
what I was trying to do with
Netflix initially, I was saying
it's like, OK, well, I
only want to invite certain
people and I don't want to
open it up to the greater
internet in general.
So can I exclude this from
ever being a service that
people would invite
to the public?
And then I just kind
of came around.
I was like, you know
what, I shouldn't
even bother with that.
Just make sure that everybody
using it is a subscriber of
that service, and that takes
care of that problem.
But just going back,
would it ever be
possible just to restrict?
JONATHAN: There's also
another solution.
If you don't publish this app,
if you keep it private and add
individuals as team members of
the application, they'll still
be able [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
application it will be
publicly available.
So that might be another
solution, especially if this
is a small app for your team
or your school or something
you're in development.
That's the right route.
JASON SALAS: OK.
Thank you.
JENNIE MURPHY: Yeah.
If any of you did Hangout app
development before the
release, that's actually the
original solution for
collaborating on the
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD DUNN: And I might add
something, which is that we're
trying to--
we're going to try to remove
this distinction between sort
of public Hangouts and then be
the developer sandbox and
actually try to roll that
into the main thing.
So that you can join a Hangout
in developer mode if you are
developer and look at your
developed apps and private
apps and things like that, but
that it's not necessarily a
separate Hangout, and so you
could invite other people to
the hang out.
They wouldn't necessarily be
able to see your private apps.
But just try to integrate that
experience and not have this
sort of separate, sand-boxed
environment.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
RICHARD DUNN: Oh, go ahead.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: No, I was
going to say, Jason, that way
I deal with that right now
is for all of my apps I
essentially have two projects.
One is the release project
and one is
the development project.
And I either don't invite or on
a very limited basis invite
people into the Hangout while
I'm doing development.
So if you catch me at the right
time, you'll see my
caption, test-- app running.
And for the most you won't.
JONATHAN: You can also do user
authentication on top of your
application.
So if you have an app engine
or an app running, you can
look at the login user and just
show a white screen, or
you don't have access to it
if they're not authorized.
RICHARD DUNN: Right.
Because you can use essentially
their Google Plus
ID to uniquely identify them.
JONATHAN: Yep.
JENNIE MURPHY: Cool.
So I have a more general
Hangouts
question, for you, Jonathan.
JONATHAN: All really?
JENNIE MURPHY: Matthew Books
asks, "how do you host a
Hangout with a simulcast
on YouTube?"
JONATHAN: So what we're in right
now is a Hangouts On
Air, and that is a product
that has been in limited
availability as we're building
out the infrastructure and the
technology.
And what that allows you to do
is take a regular Hangout,
flip a bit, and we automatically
publish that to
Google+ as a YouTube livestream,
and it lives on
youtube.com.
That feature is not yet
generally available, but we're
planning on rolling out soon.
If you have more specific
questions, there's an FAQ on
the help site that talks a
little bit more about that.
And just follow along
when that becomes
more readily available.
JENNIE MURPHY: Great.
It looks like that's all we have
on the feed for today.
So does anyone who's joined us
have anything else you'd like
to discuss?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yeah.
I actually had a general
question.
In some ways it's
kind of basic.
From reading the API, if I
remember correctly, getting
the list of users in the
Hangout, although you do get a
list of people, anyone
who's not running
your app doesn't get--
anyone who's not running your
app just shows up as there,
but with no information
at all about them.
RICHARD DUNN: Right.
So that was actually originally
a policy decision,
sort of from a privacy
perspective.
And I think this is something
that came out
of the public lunch.
There are definitely use cases
for having that stuff.
So I think the volume
app is a good
indication of that, right?
It's like, you shouldn't have to
have everyone run this app,
but I should be able to find
out this information.
I think as of today
we're actually
revisiting that decision.
And so you should expect
to see that opened up.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: OK.
And it seems to me there's some
pieces of information
that might be useful.
So even if I don't have, for
example, their ID number, it
might still be useful to at
least have their name so I
know who we are.
RICHARD DUNN: So I think we're
definitely comfortable with
doing the name and the image,
because they're part of that.
And I think the reality is that
that will probably mean
the ID will be public.
Because if you have a name and
an image, you're going to be
able to find their ID.
Right?
I mean, we're definitely
going to make the name
and the image public.
And that should be
coming very soon.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Let me
also ask a question.
This may be for--
I'm not sure if this is great
for you or for the team.
What are current best
practices on storing
configuration information
long term?
It's something I've been
thinking about a lot for the
past week or so.
And I've got assorted ideas,
and all of them have their
pluses and minuses.
So I'm curious what current
suggestions for best
practice would be.
JONATHAN: So maybe you can
elaborate on the type of
configuration.
Give an example of what kind
of data you're storing, and
then we could [INAUDIBLE].
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Pretty much
what I'm thinking of at this
point is just storing
a JSON object.
Nothing large, extremely tiny,
probably something that could
fit into a cookie or into a
local storage, but for various
reasons I don't want
to put it in there.
So we're talking something
that's probably 1k or less.
Some of it may or may not be
somewhat sensitive, so I want
to at least be able to assure
the person who's doing the
configuration that I as the
app developer won't have
access to it.
JONATHAN: So can you give me
an example of two bits of
data, one sensitive, one not
sensitive, and then I can
maybe think a little
bit more about it.
I have some options there.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yeah.
Using, for example,
a caption app.
You know, my caption app.
A non-sensitive one would just
be, predefine a bunch of
caption configurations and be
able to quickly switch between
them without having to change
the settings every time.
Or giving my preferential colors
so those show up at the
top of the list. Those
would be examples of
non-sensitive stuff.
More sensitive stuff is, in
some cases the captions
themselves could be.
Or if I'm using Hangouts
to share pictures--
what the references to those
pictures might be.
The sensitive one is probably
not so much--
it's not as fully formed, but
I can see apps where in the
future, I would be storing more
sensitive information in
there that, even if it's not
critically private, I don't
want the person thinking,
hey, wait a minute--
what other information does
this person have about me?
JONATHAN: So you mentioned
a few good ones.
Obviously, cookie
storage is one.
Local storage is another.
There's also session storage,
which gets deleted after the
session is over, which is very
similar to local storage in
that sense.
There is of course server side
storage, and you can persist
that in your database and,
with your privacy policy,
promise the user that you're
going to encrypt that or
delete it every 24 hours
or something like that.
In terms of encryption, both
in the local storage or
browser-based storage, as well
as server side storage,
there's a couple of interesting
techniques.
Hashing data is one.
That's simple enough, especially
if you hash the
values of the JSON.
There's also JSON web tokens, or
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], which is
basically encrypted JSON
with a standard.
We use that in a few places like
in-an-app payments and
things like that.
If you really want the data
stored client side and to
persisted across sessions,
really the only viable
solution I think is encrypted
local storage.
Maybe JOT is one solution
for you for that.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: OK.
Let me raise the possibility
that this be a possible API
extension in the future, being
able to provide a small chunk
of configuration space.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah.
So we have definitely thought
about providing some sort of
persistent storage.
I think in general we're trying,
when it comes to data,
we're trying to provide sort of
a basic API that will work
for most small applications.
And then anyone that wants to
write something big rolls
their own, and obviously
persistence is one of those
things that is an issue.
I think mostly we haven't
addressed it yet because it's
unclear, like, should this
be charged to the user?
Should this be charged
to the app?
That kind of thing.
How do we resolve that
piece of it?
But it's definitely on
the sort of medium
to long term goals.
In the meantime, obviously,
there's all these solutions
that Jonathan has
talked about.
JONATHAN: And just to touch on
the server side piece, if it's
something that the user needs
to change often, obviously,
App Engine and Think Query and
the different types of ways to
persist data is one solution.
If it's a configuration that
doesn't change often--
let's say a start up or their
profile information--
that could be something that's
even stored on Google Cloud
Storage as a simple JSON file.
All that stuff can be encrypted
over the wire as
well as where you store it.
So that's another thing
to look at.
JASON SALAS: And I just had
a quick two-part question.
And maybe this is more
promotional than anything.
So real fast double-edged sword
here, one, have you
heard about any app developers
building anything that
facilitate in-app payment?
Not necessarily to use the app,
but actually running the
app where you could facilitate
payment transactions?
And then two, even though we've
only been out for a few
weeks as far as the Hangout API
being officially in a 1.0
release, have you heard anybody
writing any books
about the topic?
JONATHAN: So in terms of
charging, before we had
Hangout apps, there was
ChefHangouts, I believe.
It's a service that allows
people to pay to
learn how to cook.
And they're doing some very
interesting things.
I know they're looking
at Hangout apps.
I believe some of the initial
apps that came out with the
launch either have payments
already or
are looking to payments.
Obviously, Google has
in-app payments.
We don't have a sample working
with it, but it should be
feasible to work.
And it's probably a good
solution, especially with the
price point.
RICHARD DUNN: So actually, our
PM's previous project was
in-app payments.
So we should probably get
him on that task.
JONATHAN: But yeah,
it should work.
And obviously, because
it's so new,
nobody's written any books.
And I don't know of anybody
who's writing a book
specifically about payments
in Hangouts.
JASON SALAS: Or just books about
Hangout apps in general.
I would assume that there's a
ton of people just lining up
to say, hey, I can do a really
good title on that.
I mean, it's a fascinating
topic to write a book on.
JONATHAN: And it is a
fascinating target, so it's
probably of the reasons why it
hasn't been offered yet.
But it definitely--
Google+ in general and
on the platform.
There's a lot of different
things and new approaches to
social web and social platforms.
So I think it would
make a [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD DUNN: Maybe I'll cut out
early and go write a book.
JONATHAN: Or you can
do it in Google
Docs and do it a Hangout.
JASON SALAS: There you go.
And then you can use in-app
payment and actually charge
people inside the [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN: Well, with the launch
of Google Drive, just
to sign up.
We partnered with Lulu, so you
can do publishing straight
from Google Docs.
JASON SALAS: There you go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD DUNN: I see Allen
made a comment
about GDrive, as well.
JONATHAN: Great.
RICHARD DUNN: I would love to
see a Hangout app, actually,
that did use the GDrive API.
So that would be great.
Let's do it.
JONATHAN: I actually did see
some questions before Google
Drive came out about
the DocList API.
And just to make a quick
comment, DocList API is not
part of the Google API stack,
so it cannot work with our
Google client APIs.
But it is using the old GData
implementation, which has
plenty of sample
code and APIs.
And I believe there's
even a JavaScript
client library for GData.
So you could use it straight
in the Hangout Apps.
JASON SALAS: Excellent.
JENNIE MURPHY: Well, was there
any other questions?
I don't see anything
else in the feed?
We're getting close to then end,
our scheduled end time.
So if you have any questions,
speak now or wait until the
next session.
Okey-doke.
So I think we're going to
call it a day, then.
So thanks everyone who joined
us, and everyone who commented
on the thread and participated
in other ways.
And that's it.
So we're going to
be taking off.
See you later.
JASON SALAS: All right.
Thank you, guys.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Thanks.
RICHARD DUNN: Bye bye.